in the 1950s wearing denim made you a  rebel without a cause and mainstream  acceptance lagged until one of the  world's most famous crooners challenged  the status quo in 1951 American singer  Bing Crosby tried to check into a swanky  Canadian hotel like many entertainers of  the day he was decked head-to-toe in  denim so the hotel tried to turn him  away you don't belong here  luckily a bellhop recognized him and the  singer checked in word of this denim  dilemma in Canada got back to Levis so  the companies sprang into action  they developed a custom denim jacket for  Bing Crosby it was decorated with Levi's  signature red tags and a large leather  patch labeling the denim as a tuxedo  Crosby rocked the new look and from that  moment forward denim fashion was never  the same again